[MUSIC PLAYING]
BRENNAN DOYLE: Hello, my
name is Brennan Doyle.
I'm a solution architect
at the Google Cloud,
focusing mostly on media
and entertainment vertical.
I have with me here
my friend Greg Denton,
who's a software engineer
on our render team.
We're going to talk to you
a little bit about OpenCue
and rendering.
First thing we're
going to do is we
talk a little bit about what
problem are we trying to solve.
And then I'll introduce
you to two different ways
that we can solve it on GCP.
And then we'll do an
overview of a new tool
that we've open sourced
in collaboration
with Sony Pictures
Imageworks called OpenCue.
And then we'll do a live
demo, fingers crossed.
And then Q&A at the end.
So what problem are
we trying to solve?
So basically, there has
been growing pressure
of new content being created.
So with Hulu, Netflix, all these
different content creators,
there's been an explosion
in unique scripted content.
So the need for creating
graphics has grown.
In addition to that, if you
look at what we were doing back
in the 1990s, "Titanic," for
instance, had 300 shots in it.
The last "Avengers" movie
had 3,000 shots in it.
So each individual
project that comes out
is having like a 10x growth in
the amount of graphics that are
needed to finish that project.
A somewhat popular
animation studio
claims that one of
their more recent films
took them about 33 hours
of frame to render.
And when you look
at a two hour movie,
you're looking at 24 frames a
second, 60 seconds a minute.
120 minutes is about
172,800 frames.
That's not only math, but
those are large numbers.
When you start to multiply those
by how long it takes per frame,
you're looking at 5,702,400
hours for a single revision
of an animated feature.
And time equals money.
So how do you go about
orchestrating these things
in a way that's efficient?
And that's what we're here
to talk to you about today.
So at Google Cloud,
there are two ways
we can help solve
the rendering crisis.
One of them is using
software as a service.
So it's much easier
for you to set up.
It's generally targeted
towards small and medium sized
businesses.
And the other is building
a custom pipeline
using infrastructure
as a service.
So the two things I'll
talk to you about today
are Zync Render,
which is a turnkey
solution for small and
medium business owners
to do rendering on the cloud,
mostly for burst rendering,
and then also OpenCue,
which is basically
for larger studios that
have custom pipelines, how
do we add Google help you
to build something that'll
solve problems for you.
So a little bit about Zync--
Zync is designed by
visual effects artist
for visual effects artists.
It makes it extremely
simple to render.
There are several components
that go into a Zync system.
Basically, it integrates
with your existing rendering
software.
So if you're using any
of these following tools,
it will work with these.
And it's very simple
to kick off a job
and render it in the farm.
Basically, what you
end up with is a client
that manages all of our
transfer to the cloud
from your local workstations
to the cloud copying
all the data that is
required for your rendering.
You install plugins inside of
your host 3D or 2D application.
And then there is
a web console that
allows you to manage your jobs
after they've been submitted.
So you can move
around priorities,
do troubleshooting on jobs,
things of that nature.
It's a very simple architecture.
Zync would be for yourself.
A lot of what we're
building out for you
is contained within
this Compute Engine node
right here, which
basically everything is
a black box behind the
scene happening for you.
You don't have to worry
about that infrastructure.
So basically, what
we're doing is
we're setting up
authorization for your users,
and then managing all your
transfers and renders.
So infrastructure
as a service is
more what we're going
to dig deeply into today
and take a look at OpenCue.
But basically,
the larger studios
that we work with generally
have very unique pipelines
that require them to do
very specific things.
So they need a tool
that is custom built.
So in that world,
everything is a resource.
Basically, each
piece of the puzzle
that is required to be
put together for rendering
is a resource that you
need to orchestrate.
So you start with
your render workers,
which are basically your VMs
in various sizes and flavors.
And then you can add
your persistent disks
for storing data,
additional disks that
might be needed for
holding onto your pipeline
information, things
of that nature,
object storage as a backup.
And all these need
to be orchestrated.
So when we stick
them together, we
end up with something
a little bit like this.
So rendering VMs are the root
of what we're trying to achieve
is being able to render frames.
We have some kind
of a storage, which
is where we are storing
all of our assets
that are going to be
prerequisites for renders.
We generally have some
kind of NFS file server
that is required to
either host your textures
or your pipeline for
software and such.
When we're dealing with
a hybrid conductivity,
we almost always are using
a read through cache.
And then there's some kind
of license server that
needs to be created and some
way to manage your users'
permissions as well as
something for logging,
which we use Stackdriver for
that, and your asset management
database.
And we're here to talk
to you about OpenCue.
So for what we've
built here today,
we're using Terraform templates
to build out our infrastructure
and to manage
infrastructure as code.
So it's easy to spin up,
modify, and move around
to different places
if we need it.
So let's talk a little
bit about what is OpenCue.
OpenCue is a render
orchestration layer,
or a queue management
system that we've
partnered with Sony
Pictures Imageworks
to release to the
open source community.
So it's available for
you now on GitHub.
I'll provide some links
here in just a bit.
It has been used by Sony
on hundreds of films.
It has been used in various
different deployments
as well on prem, hybrid,
and on the cloud only,
and has scaled to
many, many machines.
So OpenCue can work in a
variety of architectures.
This is not a tool that
we've released that only
works on Google Cloud.
It was developed in an
on-premise-- there we go--
way of working.
And you can see how it
would function here.
It's basically used to
distribute the thousands
or hundreds of
thousands of frames
to all of the render hosts
that you are utilizing.
It's also been used by
them quite consistently
for hybrid deployments.
Here is an example of
a hybrid deployment.
Sony last year was discussing--
they are pretty consistently
spinning up like 60,000
CPUs in the cloud
and managing them with OpenCue.
So the deployment we're
looking at here today
is basically what we are
calling a virtual studio.
So at the moment, Greg's
going to do a demo here
in just a bit.
He's running a virtual
workstation out of Oregon
that is connected to his
laptop running a software
client from Teradici and a
protocol called PC Over IP.
So if you were setting
up a studio from scratch,
it's likely that you would
want to use something
like a zero client, which
is not a computer, but just
a device that allows you connect
to that PC Over IP stream
and to stream things
back and forth.
You need some way to
connect to Google Cloud.
In this instance, we're
using the public internet.
If you were in
production, you would
be using either cloud VPN,
a dedicated interconnect,
or you'd work with
one of our partners
to share a dedicated
interconnect line.
So again, the
heart of the matter
here is a virtual
workstation running
on Google Cloud, which has an
Invidia T4 processor in it.
There we go.
And it is how we're going to
drive our Myosin file demo.
And behind that, we're only
using a single machine here.
So we're not working
through a connection broker.
But a connection
broker is a layer
that allows your artist--
if you have hundreds
of artists logging
in to a single point,
it directs them to their
particular machines
and also helps you to
manage their permissions
and log in data.
So today, we're
running our storage off
of an Elastfile
scale-out file system,
which is able to tier
to cloud storage.
So you have a
combination of ability
to customize it for high speed
and also use cloud storage
for low cost backup data.
We also have a
license server running
in the cloud, a very small Linux
VM which is serving up our MIA
licenses and V-Ray, which we'll
be doing for rendering today.
In addition to that, we
have our Cuebot server.
So a Cuebot server
is a piece of OpenCue
that I mentioned earlier.
It is managing the
distribution of the jobs.
Maintaining the
state of our database
is an OpenCue database
running on Cloud SQL, which
uses Postgres SQL.
And then we've got a
group of render workers
in the background.
So again, we've orchestrated
all of this using Terraform,
Packer, and Docker
and are currently
working on making those
scripts available to everyone
through open source.
So the types of
things that-- the
costs that you will incur
in this kind of system
are all listed out here.
I won't go through them.
I'll let you take a picture
and think about them later.
At the end of this
conversation, I'm
totally happy to answer any
questions that you have.
We also have a booth on
the far side over there
if I want to come and
have a little deeper chat.
We're way up against the back
wall there by the gaming team.
So let's talk a little bit about
the architecture of OpenCue.
So OpenCue has several pieces.
We have the-- let me
see if this works.
There we go-- the Cuebot server.
The Cuebot server
is running right now
on a VM in Google
Cloud Platform.
It is a Java service
that maintains
the distribution of
the jobs and also
enables you to log in
with a GUI and to see
the state of your current Cue.
There is the Postgres
SQL database that's
running in the background.
Those two are
communicating to maintain
a list of what jobs are
active and where all the log
files are residing.
There is this RQD
Render host over here.
These are our managed
instance groups,
which are going to be
doing the rendering for us.
They're running an RQD
process and communicating
over these ports back and
forth to the Cuebot server.
In addition, on our
artist workstation,
we have a couple of things.
A PyCue is a module that
enables us to communicate
between Cuebot and the
render hosts and the artist
workstation.
We have a tool
called CueGUI, which
is the interface for seeing the
list of jobs that are running,
how we prioritize those,
and how we assign jobs
to particular render hosts.
In addition to
that, we have a tool
called PyOutline,
which is assisting us
in submitting jobs.
OpenCue ships with a
plugin for Maya and Nuke,
which enables you just from the
interface to pull down a menu
and say, Render to OpenCue.
Also, there are
example scripts on how
you could build them for
your own customized pipeline.
So since it's open source,
if you know some Python,
you can get in there and
script your own plugins.
And then there's a
Submit Application,
which is running inside
of our host, too.
So just talk a little bit
about the infrastructure
that we're seeing and how
we're orchestrating it--
to configure and build
our render hosts,
we're using Docker images.
So basically,
those Docker images
are scripts that allow us to
define all the prerequisites,
libraries that need to be
installed as well as all
of the third party software,
and in some instances links
to where you can
check out licenses.
Those are stored in
our Container Registry.
And when we launch
a machine, we're
launching an instance
template, which
is reading in that Docker file.
We also have the-- oh
jeez, went the wrong way.
Pardon me.
We also have the ability
to resize our render hosts.
So at the moment,
what we're doing is
we're doing that manually
in this instance.
But the logic is
there that, if you
wanted to integrate your own
instance or work manager that
would look at the
size of your queue
and automatically scale
your manage instance groups
and look for health checks
and make sure that you've
got the machines you need, it
is quite straightforward to put
something together there.
So I think that covers just
about an overview of OpenCue.
Why don't we dive in and take
a look at the tool itself?
And I'll hand it over to Greg.
GREG DENTON: All right.
Hi everyone.
Thanks for coming out.
Yeah, my name is Greg Denton.
I'm a software engineer
here at Google Cloud
in the Media and
Entertainment Rendering Team.
And so if we switch
over to the demo box,
we'll jump right in and go
ahead and launch CueGUI.
So like Brennan
was talking about,
CueGUI is the
primary application
used for monitoring and
managing the render farm.
It's a side PySide II
Python application.
And it's going to
communicate back
with Cuebot, the central
server, with over GRPC.
And if we look at it
right now, there's
absolutely nothing to look
at because we have no jobs.
So we'll go over to a show and
go through launching some jobs.
So there's two APIs.
There's a general
purpose Python API
that's used primarily for
just any kind of interaction
with Cuebot.
Anything you can do in the UI,
you can do through the API.
And then there's also the
PyOutline outline API.
PyOutline is going
to help build jobs.
It gives you a lot
of functionality
to orchestrate multiple jobs
together and string them
together and submit them.
So this is just a
simple Python script
that's using those two APIs.
We'll go ahead and run it.
It's kicked off three
jobs to the farm.
And you can see that they've
shown up over here in CueGUI.
And now that we have
some jobs, let's talk
about what a job actually is
as far as OpenCue is concerned.
So a job is broken down
into three separate levels.
You have the job.
And that's really just a
container for the submission.
And if we click on
one of them, we'll
see that it hosts information
about what user submitted it,
what facility it was submitted
from, what show it's for,
what shot, that
kind of metadata.
And then if you descend
down to a separate level,
the next one down
here is a layer.
So a layer is going to be--
you can think of it as a
command to run with a frame
range associated with it.
You can have multiple
layers populating
a single job and dependencies
set up between those.
And then the layer
also is going to keep
track of the requirements
for that job.
So if you want to say
that this type of command
is going to use four
cores in this example,
that's where you're going to set
that, same for memory and GPU
requirements.
The next level down is
going to be the frame.
And the frame is going to
be the individual instance
of that command with a
single frame, or frame chunk,
depending on how your
submission set up.
And it's going to be a
command that actually
gets run on the host itself.
So we can see these guys are
all running and kicking away.
It's going to keep
track of things
like your runtime, the
exact amount of resources
that are used.
And all those stats
are then bubbled up
to the higher levels.
So you get a summary view of
what has actually been running.
So CueGUI is actually built up
as two separate applications.
You have Cuetopia, what
we're looking at here,
and CueCommander.
So Cuetopia is more
made for a single artist
looking at their jobs, trying
to see if their submissions are
running, when they'll finish,
are they finished, any errors,
that kind of stuff.
CueCommander is more made for
a admin or render wrangler
to be able to get a higher
level view of the farm,
be able to have a lot more
controls over the management
of the farm.
So as we dive a
little deeper, we'll
jump over to CueCommander.
And the first thing that we're
going to take a look at here
is the Monitor Cue View.
So this is just a high level
view of everything that's
currently active in the farm.
And you'll be able to see
this across all users.
And it gives admins the ability
to group jobs that are similar
and control them altogether.
So for instance, if
you wanted to change
the priority of multiple
jobs altogether or change
the requirements, you
could do that from here.
And so the next thing that
we're going to go over
is what groups
everything in OpenCue.
And so the highest
level object is a show.
And all jobs are going to
be submitted to a show.
You can see some really
simple information
about what kind of
cores are running,
what frames we're
running for the show.
We only have a single show here.
It's the testing show.
And we can do things from here.
I accept the maximum number
of cores, minimum number
of cores for jobs in that show.
I'll enable and disable
booking, all that kind of stuff.
All right, so we've
gone over jobs a bit.
Let's talk now about hosts.
So if we open up the
Monitor Host View--
and we'll refresh
this populate it--
this is going to show us
all of our render workers.
So the render workers
right now are all
configured to be identified
by their IP address.
And you can also have
them configured to be
identified by their host name if
that makes more sense for you.
It's pretty customizable
from that point of view.
And we can see that we have
3,000 render hosts all up
and running, thanks to
Adrian's demo from before.
And they're all still kicking.
So this view is
going to give you
a lot of information about
what type of host you have.
All of our hosts here are
running inside a single managed
instance group.
And like Brennan
was talking about,
that's running out of US West 1.
And they're reporting that
they have four cores--
all of them are idle right
now-- and 30 gigs of RAM.
So this is counting the
physical cores on the box.
So that correlates to an eight
core, 30 gig, an N1 preemptible
eight machine.
So the other information that's
useful here is the ping time.
So it's showing you
when was the last time
that machine checked in.
If that goes beyond
a certain threshold,
Cuebot is going to consider
that machine down and stop
dispatching any additional work.
And if there's any work that
was running on that that'll get
moved over to another host.
This works well for a
preemptible workflow.
Because our managed
instance group
is going to go ahead and
replace any instances that get
preempted.
And then Cuebot is going
to see that preemption
and reschedule the work for you.
So it works entirely in
a preemptible fashion
if you want.
And so let's go ahead and
go back to Cuetopia here.
And we have a bunch of
our jobs have finished.
But we have a few that
are still running.
And if we go to our hosts,
let's sort this by what's idle.
So what I'm looking for
here is a host that's
actually running something.
And one of the cool
things about OpenCue
is it has a way of
dynamically allocating slots
for jobs to run.
So like I was talking
about, all of these hosts
are four core hosts.
And let's say if you
submitted a job that's
only going to require
one core, OpenCue
is going to carve out
what's called a proc.
And that's what we're
showing down here.
And it's only going
to carve out whatever
the job requires leaving
the rest of the procs
available to be used.
So for instance, you could
run four one core products
on a single host
or two two cores,
however your job in the
dispatcher decides to do it.
So we have jobs and
hosts now covered.
How do jobs actually
get to hosts?
For that, we'll start talking
about how do we group hosts.
So there's a concept
called an allocation.
And an allocation is
really just a mechanism
for grouping multiple hosts
and controlling them together.
So we can see that all
of our render hosts
right now are running inside
this local general allocation.
And that's going to be
identified by a facility where
the host is actually running,
and then a single tag
that we want to pass to all of
the hosts in that allocation.
And then we have a subscription.
And a subscription-- whoops--
a subscription is going to
be a way of providing rules
to an allocation.
So if we select our
show, we can see
that the testing
show has subscribed
to the following allocations.
And here, we can also specify
the amount of resources
from that allocation that
we want the host to have,
as well as a burst amount.
The burst amount is going
to allow multiple shows
to share a single allocation
and be able to steal resources
when available there.
And so the next
thing-- if that's
our way of grouping
and managing hosts,
services are our mechanism for
grouping and managing jobs.
So every job can be
submitted to a service.
In this case, we're looking
at the Arnold service.
And it's going to provide
some for default resource
requirements for that job.
The job can specify anything
else it wants on top of that,
but these are going
to be the difference.
In this case, you're
able to specify that it's
going to be threadable.
It's going to be able to use
however many threads you want.
And the minimum
number of threads
required-- this is
a percentage amount.
So saying that it is
100 here means that it's
going to use one core.
You can obviously go above that.
And then the maximum is
set at zero, essentially
saying that there's no maximum.
We are also specifying
minimum memory requirements
for that proc.
So it's only going to carve
out a proc from the host
if that memory is
available and if there's
any GPU requirements.
The last thing that the
service is going to do
is apply these tags to
the jobs that are there.
So now, putting
this all together,
if we go back to our Cuetopia
view and look at these jobs,
we can select the job and
look at its attributes.
And we can see that it
is, in fact, submitted
to the local facility.
And it's using the testing show.
And then if we select our layer
and look at its attributes,
you'll be able to see that
it's using this shell service,
in this case.
And it's picking up the
util and general tags.
So with that information,
we're able to figure out
what allocation is
eligible to run that job
and what host it should go to.
So if we go to our
job that's running
and select one of the
frames that has finished
or one of the frames
that's running,
we can view the
log for that job.
And we'll make this
a little bigger here.
And so this is just the
standard out and standard
error from whatever
process was running.
In this case, it's the VRA log.
And if we look at
the succeeded one,
we can search here
for written image.
And that's going to give us
the path to the file that
was actually output.
We can go over here,
where I already have that
and launch RV.
And our frames are here.
So that's launching and
running a simple job.
This is just a single layer,
one command over multiple time
frames.
Things get a lot
more complicated
when you start talking about
dependencies and hooking up--
I want a layer to wait until all
the frames of one job are done,
or other connections.
OpenCue supports dependencies
at each of the different job
levels--
job, layer, and frame.
And you can hook up as many of
those dependencies as you want.
So we jumped over
here to Maya now.
And I'll walk through what
it looks like submitting
a job with dependencies.
This is from our
robot dance party
animation that was produced
here at Next last year.
And we've set it up this
time for V-Ray and Maya.
So it's all ready to go.
And we'll launch the
CueSubmit plugin.
Like Brennan was
talking about, this
is shipped as a
plugin inside Maya.
But you can also launch the
CueSubmit widget from a command
line if you want.
And you can configure it
to run any kind of command.
So we'll populate this
with some information.
This is just basic job info.
So the job name, all this
stuff is already in my history.
So I'm just pressing
down to populate it.
And we'll do the lighting
pass and this is our Maya file
that we have open.
We'll select the render camera
and give it a frame spec.
So we'll just run
frames 230 through 250.
We'll set our Maya service and
give it a minimum core of four.
And for this layer, we
want it to run right away.
So we'll go ahead and leave
the dependency to none.
But we'll add another layer.
And we'll say that this
is our FFmpeg pass.
So we want to do
something like run a make
movie after all the
frames are done,
so that way we can combine
everything together.
And I have a command
to do that over here.
We'll copy that in.
And since this is just going
to be a single command,
we only want it to run once.
And we'll say it's just
going to run on frame one.
And for this, we'll leave
the default service.
And it's only going
to consume one core.
And we'll set it to
be a layer dependency.
So that's meaning
that this layer
is going to wait until all the
frames from the lighting layer
have finished.
And we'll go ahead and submit.
Get our confirmation,
close that.
And if we jump over to
Cuetopia, I'll refresh here.
And wait for our job.
There's our job.
Now, it has come in.
And if we double
click it, we can
see that there are
two layers here now.
The lighting layer is
using the Maya service.
FFmpeg is using the default one.
And the frame range is
associated with that.
And you'll see all the frames
for all the layers by default.
You can filter out
individual layers
if you want to view just
the frames from one layer,
but we'll leave it like
this for right now.
And you can see that the
lighting layers are running.
And the FFmpeg layer
is marked as Depend.
So it's going to
sit there waiting
until all of our running
frames finish up and go.
And so a couple other things
I just wanted to go over--
you saw me going up here to
this Views plugin menu a lot.
All these separate
widgets in CueGUI
are really built on
a plugin structure.
So it's really easy with
just a little bit of Python
to go in and add
your own widgets.
If you want to
have a display that
hooks up to more historical
data, you can create that.
If you want something
that's tied into Shotgun,
you can build that out as well.
And that about covers
it for the demo.
We can switch over back
to the presentation.
And to give you
just an illustration
of what was going on with
the dependencies, here's
the dependency DAGs
that were submitted.
So this was the lighting
render with the FFmpeg.
You can see that
the frames are all
feeding into the FFmpeg layer.
And that's how that
dependency is working.
But these kind of
dependency DAGs
can get pretty complicated
pretty quickly.
And OpenCue is going to
ensure that no frames are
run until after all the
dependencies are met.
[MUSIC PLAYING]